hello and welcome to this video blitz
game against a down low okay yeah I
don't have a great line against the
ragazza I tried the screen a form but I
got good into trouble there okay I'll
play this III year witches yeah so
somewhat somewhat modest move but it
will transpose in most cases to the
Rubenstein nims Oh after c5 and this is
not bad of course so I think recently
white players have tried this then aged
3 i'm not quite sure what the point is
and to be honest who is taking here
that's interesting hmm
and ce4 is probably a critical move here
hmm but unsure it looks like the
critical move 95 maybe we should be true
something like that I've seen something
similar with a three Bishop f5 we just
takes hmm surprising
hmm yeah i would think that white should
be in good shape Queen Quincy five this
Bishop a three okay mighty Khan f3 okay
I think I'm I'm just covering this first
and then see what's going on queen bee
three now maybe to threaten Bishop e3
and look at the b7 pawn it just looks
like a wide open position where I have
fun the bishop parent one additional
porn in the center so it would be
surprising if it is so it wasn't
slightly better for Wyatt here still
Bishop e3 and that's quite annoying okay
it goes back
go into h4 maybe just all the way back
our bag is wrong all the way to the
other side of the board Queen can be
useful yeah with Bishop b2 may be coming
hmm interesting
technically somewhat shaky but don't see
something clear you should a three isn't
isn't anything okay I think I'll take a
plane idea form it should be a little
bit better for wide at least
hmm okay
can it just straight here Knight to c4
might happen okay he will go b6 I'm
threatening would be five now winning a
night but he will play b 6i guess okay
that's also addressing the this is this
issue but
hmm i was still expecting v6 I think
this might end up weakening the beep on
here should be too why is not c4 just
just about
hmm a bit slow here should should speed
up some what did I have G for now it's
an interesting move I think let's try
that I Scott night f4 and oh ok didn't
didn't look for this kind of opportunity
my dear for was interesting as my knight
on d4 was unprotected maybe that was
good for him ok
we are checking here doesn't lead to
much
okay since I cannot stay on the on the
sick rank chicking King up does it help
so okay I go back
interesting time morning covering
covering this technically g-form ideas
night f5 and then possibly trying to
address them on the back rank I never
before it's not a great idea I my
playbook c4 here hmm that might happen
like him one day I could have prevented
that
I mean problem here is that I'm on
30-something seconds position is pretty
good I think yeah it's actually winning
but still at the time can prove to be
tricky check I'm plundering this point
that I don't believe this [ __ ] oh my
goodness check still critical of M H
porn is quite dangerous
kingi for wasn't a good idea i think i
should go the other way check yeah that
wins now for what I think check check
check check check under its chance Jerry
got four seconds there's no way to avoid
the Queen's right here I'm still winning
I think I'm not sure four seconds check
check game drag yeah I know it's a dryer
to play me at him ah yes hmm yeah was it
was tough I'm in the position I was i'm
quite quite comfortable here always with
the wide open position to bishops or the
other advantages here like the knight on
d4 and still um it wasn't totally easy
we know anything it was just better for
wide now your night f4 was interesting
but okay
yeah yeah I'm just in good shape the
only question is winning or not and I
think I played it reasonably okay here
Jackie I'm probably winning 1.24 white
EW p5 is even better why hmm he is
drawing that and I'm not sure f4 strong
okay I'm trapping the night down there
for strapping the night yeah it's not
much to look this position is just a
tool win for wine that end game is also
lost but I just I just take a five year
sometimes i'm just at least stupider I
mean this is also winning but taking a
five is just ending the game and here it
still gets kind of interesting Knight c3
Jeff instead of t6 yeah okay the hippie
place that now check and now it's
probably something probably equal but he
blended it back again somehow a 94 now
is spinning anyway I cannot I cannot
look at the game if if if if they place
some kind of stuff in the notices all
the time um yeah of course what's pretty
tough at the end check check check the
solution is so check check check quite
funny because yeah okay here King g7 is
just it's just promoting check yeah
whatever yeah this is winning for white
buddy we don't need to look at this I'm
just promoting this pawn and you're lost
but ok the time it was impossible
impossible to I don't see the point
anyway okay next time I should just play
quicker thanks for watching